science breakthroughs from science
mission the mechanisms that drive eamon
illogical responses targeted to the CNS
remains largely unknown on blood-brain
barrier disruptions like you see in
traumatic brain injury stroke as a mass
disease and other dementias fibrinogen
achshav assets into cns and is converted
to fibrin upon activation of coagulation
fibrin interns activates cd11b cd18
present on the microglia and macrophages
to stimulate chemokine release leading
to recruitment of peripheral
inflammatory macrophages monocytes and
t-cells fibrin also induces antigen
presenting properties and provides
instructive signals such as
interleukin-12 for inducing th one cell
differentiation these actions lead to
implement re demyelination these results
might help to develop novel therapies
targeting early and late events in neuro
inflammatory and neurodegenerative
diseases next authors in the journal
Nature communications show that some
women develop cholestasis due to the
lack of biliary transporter like ABC b11
resulting in increased bile acid levels
bile acids get transported to the fetus
and interferes with the development of
surfactant structure leading to
breathing problems and mortality the
nutrient factor was deleted in mice
lacking abcb transporter about sixty
percent of the babies recover due to
decreased serum bile acids partly due to
the decreased levels of intestinal bile
acid uptake proteins this paper thus
provides new strategies to protect
babies with cholestasis mother for more
news visitors at www science mission
calm or science mission facebook page
thanks for watching